here to react is House Minority Whip and
Louisiana congressman Steve Scalise
Carson thank you so much for being here
this morning appreciate it give us more
time good to be with you absolutely
great to have you give us the top line
on this you know we needed something and
we needed it quick it's a big price tag
what are we getting and do you have any
reservations well when you have a
problem like we have with the the
economy really being shut down in most
sectors for for over week now you saw
great companies that we're literally
hanging on by a thread this bill was
really designed to help families and
businesses so that we can have an
economy to come back to when we get
through this there's also a lot in there
to help hospitals that are struggling
too so you know if you look at the bill
you know any large bill like this and
quite a largest relief package in the
history of the country 2.2 trillion
dollars but clearly a massive response
to all of the massive things we're
seeing layoffs companies that are trying
to figure out if they're gonna be able
to make it through this this bill will
really give them that ability to go get
loans that can be forgiven to keep their
payrolls so that you don't see millions
more unemployed like you saw just last
week 3 million people that were added to
the unemployment rolls you know you
can't see an economy sustain itself like
that and this bill is designed to help
those families to help those companies
stay afloat through all of this
congressman I want to ask you about
Louisiana because it's now emerging as
the next possible epicenter of the virus
cases have climbed 30 percent in just 24
hours so what do you make of that right
now just to take a look at Louisiana
2746 cases 119 deaths so what do you
make of the news and what are you hoping
for in terms of the approach from people
in leadership positions in that state
you know in the last week we saw New
Orleans pop up to be one of the top
hotspots next with New York and you know
we've seen a number of additional cases
going to the hospitals we were able to
work with the administration about a
week and a half ago to get an extra 7500
tests per kid to set up a new pod site a
pilot program in New Orleans that was
set up in a few other cities that were
hotspots so you can test more people of
course that means there going to be more
positives but you know there is an
increased number of cases and an
increase
number of deaths there's a nursing home
facility in my district where we've
already lost 11 people that have died
more positive in that facility
we got CDC to send an expert down just
the other day I've been working closely
with our governor with our mayor and
local officials to make sure that we can
get everything we can from the federal
government to recognize the the
increased hotspot in New Orleans
congressman you're preparing there in
Louisiana and particularly in New
Orleans like never before you know the
death rate though specifically in New
Orleans accounts for more than 50% of
those roughly one out of every 10,000
New Orleans residents has died of
coronavirus right now you have perhaps a
crisis the likes of which we haven't
seen outside of New York are you worried
you've got what you need well you know
anytime you see that number and like I
said 11 deaths at one facility is
heartbreaking it's alarming but you know
you see everybody coming together
federal state and local to do everything
they can clearly like all the other
places in this country where they're
seeing the outbreak you know we still
don't have a cure they're trying a lot
of different new therapies some that are
proven for other things like malaria but
there's no one silver bullet for
coronavirus so we're gonna continue work
and I I've been working with our local
hospitals in New Orleans and they're
doing heroic work I know y'all have
pointed that out too they're on the
front lines but they're still going in
helping patients and setting up testing
clinics at remote locations so that
people can go there instead of the
hospital be tested and then if they have
severe problems obviously you want the
hospitals right now reserved for those
people that have the most serious
illnesses absolutely car vs. Steve
Scalise thank you so much for your time
and we will certainly be paying a lot of
attention to your backyard as we should
God thank you and God bless